Well,
I,
I always love working with which
scorsese because,
um,
he,
he had the confidence to know,
unlike a lot of directors,
he had the confidence,
you know exactly what he wanted and he
said,
okay,
you're the writer,
give me this.
And he didn't fret over it.
He just went off and,
you know,
set up his shots and,
you sort of trusted me to deliver the
goods.
A lot of guys are like so anxious that
they never know what they want and you
get caught in the middle.
Um,
you get into power plays between actors
and directors and you know,
you fit,
you,
you know,
you feel like a secretary.
What a dog collar on.
Um,
but I never,
you know,
which Scorsese,
it was like,
he just knew exactly what he wanted and
you know,
it was a breeze.
I mean,
it's never easy,
but it was relatively,
it was a breeze.
Other people I worked with that I really
liked is a David Simon and,
and the crew around the wire.
Uh,
the only reason to do that show other
than you sure don't do it for the money.
I mean,
you open up the envelope and um,
you know,
moths fly out.
But,
um,
you do it cause it's the wire and it
was,
it seemed like a,
like a group of peers,
although it wasn't cause Simon was to
create her,
he and Ed Burns,
you know,
they,
they were the writer,
producer,
creator is always the guy that rewrites
everything and is in control.
But given that there was none of the
Games,
uh,
it was me and Pelicano Pelecanos and
Lehane and,
and Ed Burns and David Simon.
And I felt like when we were all
together,
you know,
there was,
there was a,
a sobriety,
you know,
of purpose,
um,
and,
and a mutual sympathy and respect,
you know,
for each other's work that I rarely find
in,
in group situations like movie making.
And it was just a great show.
I'm,
although I frankly,
it was so hard,
I didn't even understand my own scripts
most of the time,
but,
you know,
I did,
did what I was told,
you know,
and then some.
And,
uh,
I was just really proud to be part of
that,
you know.